so what would be the perfect meal to
help you detoxify your liver that's what
we're going to talk about today
the first thing I want to mention is
that
going through a detox is not the same as
a cleanse there's all these cleanses out
there that say like a 14 day cleanse
clean out your liver right well don't
waste your money going on a cleanse with
cayenne pepper and lemon juice with
maple syrup
for for even a week or two is not going
to help you clean your liver all these
expensive little kits with these
powdered herbs and things that you can
take to cleanse your liver are not going
to in any significant way
clean your liver and I'm going to
explain why you have some powerful
amazing thing that happens in that cell
they go through like this assembly line
of
enzymatic changes okay got phase one
in phase two and then phase three is
just the full elimination of that Toxin
and when I talk about toxins I'm talking
about drugs medication preservatives
xenobiotics which are all the chemicals
that are external to the body and
foreign to the body like you have
Plastics you have petroleum products you
have also mold and fungus and pesticides
insecticides herbicides fungicides you
have metabolic waste like hydrogen
peroxide you have toxins from smoking I
think there's over
six or seven thousand different
chemicals okay with about I think 74 to
a hundred uh
carcinogens then you have chemicals in
vaping you have caffeine heavy metals
I'm not sure if I mentioned that
cleaning chemicals alcohol hormones that
need to be broken down so we are
basically swimming bathing in chemicals
24 7 especially if you use tap water and
it's like in your shower head and you
have to drink that and I mean it's just
it's hitting us from every different
angle thank goodness we have this system
of phase one phase two detoxification
and the whole goal of this process is to
turn poisons into harmless
water-soluble particles so in other
words a lot of these chemicals are fat
soluble so let me explain fat soluble so
you can see right here
we have fat and we have water right
do you know they don't mix this is the
fat soluble toxins right here it goes
into the body but it doesn't come out it
gets stuck in there so we need to turn
this fat into something that's more
water-soluble so it can go through the
body
so
what these enzymes do
is basically add
something
to the fat and then
and so they break it down into something
that can actually go through the body
okay this is another example that I use
with like bile salts and what bile salts
can do for fat but it's a good analogy
also for what these enzymes do to the
fat soluble poisons in phase one they're
adding you know either water hydrogen or
oxygen to start to oxidize and break it
down the challenge with this phase one
okay is that when this chemical is
activated it becomes more toxic more
dangerous more of a carcinogen because
you're adding oxygen and you're
oxidating it and you're opening it up
that's why we have phase two but we need
phase one to be able to dismantle this
so then we can then add the next thing
to this chain of events so phase one
kind of starts the process it activates
things it requires certain nutrients
like folate vitamin C certain B vitamins
calcium Etc and this is also the phase
where if you consume grapefruit juice
right or grapefruit and you're also
taking a medication there's a certain
chemical in grapefruit that will retain
that drug longer in your system and it
will make things more toxic for you so
you never want to consume grapefruit
juice or grapefruits while you're taking
a certain medication and during phase
one there's a lot of free radicals and
oxidation happening and this is where
you need a lot of antioxidants so
antioxidants protect the cell against
all this free radical stuff going on and
detoxification is different because
you're taking a poison and turning into
a water-soluble harmless particle now
after phase one gets a hold of that
poison then phase two comes in there and
it does something called conjugation
okay and that's basically adding a water
soluble double molecule to this compound
like for example glutathione so
glutathione binds with it and now it's
water soluble and if you ever get a DNA
test you'll see all these detoxification
enzymes and you can actually see if you
have a problem with them genetically
like like say there's just a mutation
with one of those enzymes and what that
means is there's some sluggishness and
that enzyme doesn't work like it should
so it makes you more susceptible
to damage from that poison if you're
exposed to it it's just going to be
harder for your body to get rid of that
toxin unless you eat very healthy and
you do things to really avoid that toxin
so the value of a DNA test will tell you
the importance of avoiding a certain
toxin or going above and beyond what you
normally do to eat certain things to
help this process happen faster and when
I'm actually evaluating DNA testing I'm
finding a lot of people have a problem
with these detoxification enzymes so in
Phase One okay the name of this group of
family of enzymes are called the
cytochrome p450 enzymes okay and then in
phase two you have a bunch of other
names involving glutathione but I'm not
going to get into these names at this
point just realize that all these
enzymes pretty much do the same thing
but in different locations in the body
and with different toxins so like I said
before there are detoxification enzymes
in your intestines in your lungs in your
kidney
liver is a primary area of
detoxification so with phase two you're
attaching
certain water-soluble compounds to help
it become more water-soluble and that
involves sulfur choline certain amino
acids zinc now there's a couple points
I'm going to talk about with this whole
assembly line of enzymes to break down
these chemicals it really depends on how
chronically you're exposed to these
chemicals for example if you have a bad
habit of smoking okay every day for a
long period of time that is going to be
way more of a problem with these enzymes
and the accumulation in chronic
irritation and the side effects of
things like cancer because remember
cancer is this chronic irritation or
damage to the mitochondria that then
switches over into this out of control
cancer cell well something causes it and
it's usually The Chronic exposure to
something and it can also be diet as
well and on top of that if someone has a
fatty liver which the majority of the
population does
this phase one phase 2 detoxification
enzyme pathway just does not work like
it should also if they have inflammation
in the liver same thing like hepatitis
it just won't work that well and
especially if they have cirrhosis it
won't work that well now there's also a
phase three detoxification where you're
eliminating these water-soluble
chemicals throughout the body but what
if for example you are constipated right
your bowels hold on to these toxins
well that's a problem because they
accumulate especially if you have
chronic constipation and another thing
you can have is like dysbiosis which is
an alteration in the gut microbiome
there's a gut liver relationship that if
there's something going on the gut it's
going to affect the liver because the
friendly bacteria also assist in
removing these chemicals so if you had a
lot of antibiotics or you have an
overgrowth of yeast or a lot of problems
with the gut microbiome you can have a
problem with detoxification now a little
bit higher up in the digestion you have
these bile ducts bile is one of the
primary ways of eliminating these toxins
okay as well as through the urinary
system but if there's anything going on
in the bile ducts where there's a
blockage that's called cholestasis where
there's just like sludge or an
obstruction from a gallstone that can
start accumulating these toxins in the
liver and interrupt this flow that
should normally happen and the way that
you would know that you would have that
is usually like right shoulder pain or a
fullness underneath the right rib cage
or burping or belching and the remedy is
to thin the bile with more bile and I
like to use a remedy called Tut cut
which has been known to greatly assist
in the detoxification process of the
liver and in other parts of the body
what about if the urine is obstructed
okay I mean let's say the person has in
a large prostate and they just don't
eliminate like they should and they
retain urine well we have this
accumulation of toxic material that just
cannot exit the body and it backs up all
the waste not to mention someone that
having diabetes and having a kidney
problem which also causes them to retain
these chemicals but the question is what
can you do about it what can you do well
the diet out of all the things you can
do and I'm talking about supplements and
remedies and all this stuff
diet can help you the most when you
detoxify and I'm not talking about a
two-week cleanse I'm talking about
something you do on a routine basis a
consistent basis where you're eating
these Foods over and over and over again
so I'm going to describe a meal that I
think would be the best meal to help
your liver and other organs detoxify we
want to start with the egg okay eggs are
one of the perfect Foods because they're
high in Sulfur
complete amino acid profile they pretty
much have every nutrient including
choline which is really good for the
liver as well as a fatty liver and then
you would cook those eggs with onions
and garlic two things that are very high
in Sulfur not to mention all the
antioxidants in onion and garlic that
can help counter the phase one
detoxification and don't forget the sea
salt to get some of the trace minerals
and then we add our cruciferous
vegetables now there's any number of
cruciferous vegetables that you can do
you can do roasted brussels sprouts you
can do cauliflower or you can do
broccoli steamed broccoli or even
cabbage or sauerkraut and if you want to
do a salad you can just do arugula the
more bitter the vegetable the better for
your liver out of all the salad greens
arugula is at the top of the list
because it's cruciferous these
cruciferous vegetables activate the
genes that cause these enzymes to be
produced and work so if you have a
genetic mutation with one of these genes
consuming those foods can speed up this
process now just so you know this is my
meal this is what I eat very often as my
first meal of the day and then as a kind
of a dessert I'll have kefir which is
way better than yogurt then I'll put
some walnuts in there and sometimes I
might put some low carb no sugar
chocolate chips just a little bit that's
my dessert but that can actually help
with the calcium that you need as well
as is to your microbiome what's unique
about kefir is that it has a lot more
friendly bacteria as well as friendly
yeast whereas yogurt has less bacteria
and no friendly yeast and of course
that's not the only meal but that's just
an example of something that could be
good you definitely want enough protein
too with complete amino acids because
all these enzymes are made from amino
acids so it's very very important to
have some animal meat or eggs with your
meal and to put the icing on the cake I
probably shouldn't talk about cake
add additional herbs if you can if you
can add you know thyme Sage oregano
cayenne pepper turmeric Rosemary any of
these herbs are going to help you in the
detoxification process now if you
haven't seen this video on how to get
rid of a fatty liver
I put it up right here check it out